Middleton tipped it to himself holiday
Crowder and working around the Ingles
driving a holiday scores to tie the game
at 96. timeout Phoenix so the seven
point lead for Phoenix disappeared in
about two minutes here's Paul driving
needs to Cutter block Lopez against
ayton ayton gets it back then lost it
out of bounds and it's Milwaukee ball I
remember all year now Lopez has been
right up there in the top three or four
in shot blocking he gets holiday to
Middleton akogi's on holiday shot clock
nearing 10. holiday long one
[Applause]
team of the foul to give Booker turning
the corner angle was cut off by holiday
now he backs him down turn around good
Booker ties the game at 100. I just
watch it she's right on him he's up on
the challenge and Booker was to knock
that down Big Shot Devin Booker again
started 0-4-6
and Banda Lopez now Middleton
down lowest Lopez
right Milwaukee by two
[Applause]
15 to shoot 16 of the game clock Booker
drives lost it and Lopez had to have
holiday
and they're going to call it foul and
then under under pressure can handle as
well as if any big guy that size if he
misses it Milwaukee does have a foul to
give and he did miss it out of bounds I
think Ross touched it last they're gonna
say it's Phoenix Ball but I think Ross
touched it back oh they're going to
challenge it right now Milwaukee has the
challenge they're going to look at I
think that's off Ross even though it's
ruled that it's son's ball
well they were worried about
why would they didn't use the challenge
back well the fact that bud didn't do it
I kept his right his pocket right there
was a foul Phoenix Augustus that play is
under further review
and ruling in the court is off of
Middleton can you tell with certainty
that it is off of Ross there
serious ly
with that angle you can't see whether
there's a separation well once you could
see Middleton definitely touches the
ball right there now did Ross get a
piece of that as it rolls off his
fingers
they need a better angle it did look
like it changed Direction
it looks like it's off of Ross to me but
again
it has to be have a timeout they have
trouble getting the ball in bounds
there's a lot of the holiday dangerous
pass
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a quick double team the lead
left the man in the middle of the floor
to come to double on that and then they
say precious sign the clock is at 10
seconds
now the pressure is can you make the
foul shots and Ingles
was the inbounder
so Drew holiday is a terrific free-throw
shooter is at the line
career-high 86 percent on the season for
holiday
and it's a four-point lead
he's three for three tonight 33 points
the Bucks looking to extend their win
streak to 14 in a row the longest in the
NBA this season they won nine in a row
at home
missed the second one loose ball
and again the sun's down four five
seconds left
Ingles can't foul here on Booker but he
did and he almost made the shot
hit the front rim he'll shoot three
down four that's the one thing Ingalls
couldn't do and he almost
[Applause]
gave Booker a chance to tie the game all
right this is just incredible he jumped
into him there's no doubt about that now
about on on the move you know
he's got to make two right now and then
miss them one and then get the rebound
and can you do it up see that that's
been the problem all night tonight on
the foul line for Phoenix hookers missed
three free throws that's right their
best free throw shooters who shoot it
religiously every year 84 85 percent
you got that one the Phoenix is 13-21
now you got to miss and hope you get it
battered out for a three yeah and let's
face it nine tenths of a second uh it's
miraculous but you never know
so again you gotta Miss and somehow have
it pinball out to a three-point shooter
[Applause]
foreign
must hit the rim
and that's the game Milwaukee's win
streak
extended despite Gianna's not playing
the Bucks have won 14 in a row 10
straight at home
they beat the Phoenix Suns 104. 101 is
true holiday put on a show 33 points
the Bucks remain in the Lost column tied
with Boston Atop The East
the sun's fall to 33 and 29. don't
forget Lakers Mavs on ABC up next for
Hubie Brown Cassidy hubber Sunday pass
thanks for watching the NBA on ABC Home
of the NBA finals
[Music]